here's David Tao no bumping mics I never
doing what's going on my in stop the
party no no we were waiting for you was
that Brian Posehn but his eyes publicist
[ __ ] up I heard that he's flying in I
heard that on the last station yeah
where is he coming from Austin I don't
know I don't know we got [ __ ] today at
Dave we got away I mean every which way
any time every time we turn around some
comedian there's no shelters here now
he's I take care of things
you bring little treats Sharklets no man
the Supreme Court all right all right
[Laughter]
you certainly do Jim did you get a shirt
no I didn't you sure you sure about that
positive Dave I think I got your hat
what did you do Travis oh my god what
the [ __ ] I tried to fire the pad data
for the Dave Attell and I just I hit the
our producers trying to go Dave I want
you to know something we're being
sabotaged in every turn
yeah I can tell look at this Mike's man
what happened wasn't lighting to stay on
the air right what how are you having an
unplugged in here was Lisa do you have
any more shirts not even like you so I'm
a little fella please let me see the Hat
I just try it on maybe I'll probably
take the gift you get point hat oh my
this is not working my thing is not work
your headphone you turn up pump up the
volume as they say and then yeah put
your headphones on over the Hat please
yeah I don't have a good head that's
incredible oh that's got a big bear
you're right clumsy piece of [ __ ]
chocolate by the way with the front [ __ ]
cut open I can only imagine what hole
that's the commercials let me get it
stupid do I Troy thanks I'm actually
gonna go ahead and throw it out my ig
stories - oh now just because I think
look at me Jim I don't want to think you
look really good usually a fat guy
t-shirts to excess I was concerned
Dave I was concerned I was much stupid
it might happen I think I look pretty
pretty good yeah not stupid at all now
you look like you're a reporter for like
a Detroit rock magazine kid Kid Rock
yeah and you get the flat brim and
everything don't bend that brim you look
swollen I'm just gonna fill myself in
this hat I'll put it up I really thought
it was really great it actually it looks
better yeah well what are you looking at
me for
well because I wanted people to know
that I wasn't making that compliment up
thank you they can hear his voice they
don't think that's you broaden your
voice if I put it on Instagram they
might not know that's Ryan is a good guy
this is vote wow really wow yeah that
really was him as a kid I guess so he
lost a lot of weight he looks skinnier
that's why that's why he missed his
flight he's at the gym maybe [ __ ]
scheduled today Joey Diaz just didn't
contact anybody Joey Diaz no showed us
twice in a row twice as hard to guess
over the holidays it must be right
comedians by the way I mean Dave we got
the number one comic in the world in
here today Italian I'm talking about
Dave comes no one likes doing morning
radio it's [ __ ] stinks yeah but I
like it when it's fun like you guys are
fun so this is cool I just been getting
up nobody likes getting up at 6:00 in
the morning you know what was fun I
wouldn't you get up because when I see
Jim later in the day because he does
spots every night sure he's like he
looks so exhausted yeah and I'm like I
wonder what it you know like what what's
going on I know I do morning radio so I
assume that you stay up all the way till
when you have to do the spots you get to
take a little nap no I'm not a good nap
er yeah see that's the thing I don't
sleep well my problem is now that I come
down to these two hour sleeps which is
the worst like that really is bad wait
two hours sleeps her naps
no that's my whole sleep it's two hours
and then like another two hours later in
the in the 24 hour cycle so you try to
get for two hour sleeps in a day to get
your 8 no no I get 2 2 2 2 2 hours so
that's 4 that's it why are you not
sleeping I don't know I have trouble
sleeping to begin with but like four
hours is better the two hour one you're
constantly thinking of like I have to
get up in two hours right that's all
thing so you'll be up like through the
year but say like you eat up at 8:00 for
a flight you'll be up until like [ __ ]
5 o'clock in the world exactly yeah and
when you wake up are you up or can you
fall back asleep no I'm up that's it
think you have sleep apnea I'm sure I
have that yeah how does that matter
I can't rhyme too claustrophobic I need
to sign a surgery again the whole thing
so you actually have the surgery I did
years ago 2008 and I got the mask but I
can't wear it because it still presses
down on my [ __ ] dumb no so I know I
use a Breathe Right strip they could
never use it I can never get you really
forcing hear in my mouth no breather
right strip actually work it does I show
open JEP y'all
yeah well that's good sleep is important
especially for you guys important for
all of us just as humans you know I know
but you guys have a schedule you have
you have to get up at a certain time oh
yeah I seen you guys are up like
probably 3:00 in the morning I'm not
just 4:30 4:30 right you hit the gym
right not well okay come on Jimmy I go
after you go after after yeah that's
great
yeah no I'm not hitting any gyms is it
fun at the gym when people come over hey
today you said on the show do they ask
for like a little more they don't you
know they don't care no producers don't
care what would they that's a good point
yeah
I mean Dave you literally walked in our
producers tried to send us to commercial
break that what we're dealing with yeah
it's tough right button it's tough times
well maybe it's the holidays you should
give him a second chance and we're right
I'm gonna tell you something to Dave
it's the producer that just almost said
it's a commercial break could be no
enricher stinger we literally spent an
hour talking about who is talking about
how he had been [ __ ] up all year
really and then he just added another
one to the list today that reminds me of
[Laughter]
you know what was it we're alive man out
we do will you put them here well
there's snowmen but they're not Santa
they're snowman that's holding the wrong
damn sorry that's okay but the mine is
ripped and I can't eat this it's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah there's a little penis sticking
through and it's like they've got that
one for you that's what I have romaine
lettuce inside there how was Pete
Dominic show I was leaving mouse beach
yes great it's great that was more of a
mano a mano here this is more of a yeah
I don't know what you could say we like
to call it up zoo zoo crew in the
morning just right just she does radio
in Vancouver and wanted to come in and
just Vancouver let's talk about it yeah
I've been dying to go back there but the
deal is never right or the flight is
never right so how is it going there I
definitely have to get up there I've
only done one gig there it's tough to
get there from New York it was a
nightmare yeah yes it's a hard flight
there's usually a over six and a half
six and a half with the winds yeah I
mean honestly it's really tough how do
you do it do you go through Calgary um
you know I did layover but I want to say
Minneapolis but don't hold me to much
the way to do it might have been this
back I [ __ ] up I came back on a
red-eye 'xs I had a vacation fall short
due to the life just collapsing and
laughter yeah you know watch maybe
paddleboard
I was gonna go through the gardens sure
the beautiful flowers of Vancouver and
then I want to take you a red-eye home
you know he was unscheduled leave nine
days early
I don't know that vacation cuz you were
very excited you told me yeah yeah yeah
yeah a home in 24 hours and you said you
did yeah I can't wait for the long
vacation I have yep and I looked at your
Instagram you're on a flight home yes I
was sick I haven't even left LA yeah but
it was odd that I took a red-eye which
means you have to go through [ __ ]
customs in the US because they Canada
closes it at night we go through customs
in Canada so is a [ __ ] nightmare cuz
I had a lot of luggage you know planning
for a 10-day trip right in the middle of
the trip or you just said I'm not gonna
go did we we I did 10% of my trip and
was I'm not a vacation guy I'm not
either
yeah don't whether you were what
happened no I'm not but I never I've
never canceled 10% in like if I do a
vacation it's always been a hundred
percent of the vacation or at least like
80 I would say right but to cancel at
10% our vacation has to go catastrophic
ly bad was it bad
Jim yep over all the places that you
could go this way I know I know it was
just to do it I had wanted to know
saying that like you can go like you're
only like two hours away from the
islands or something where LA Vancouver
was just a place to I had done the gig
there and I wanted to spend more time
there I loved it
um I went to 1990 it was wonderful I got
blow job at an alley in 1990 I was six
months in the comedy I spent I gave I
had 80 American dollars left I had no
money back there and I gave a girl sixty
and her other friend said you could Pat
my bum for 20 and I rubbed my knee yeah
they're trying to get that here yeah fly
with Momo is training up in here sure
eventually eventually it's gonna happen
it does it then we have to do it yeah
this is what we do on this show well
where is it huh what kind of the smoke
welcome to the smoke Club you guys are
gonna like the Cheech and Chong but
instead of of a weed you guys are of
talk yes you know I had it I at a moment
I was leaving the Comedy Cellar area
doing chips podcast we were I was
leaving and I was in that parking lot
you know next to the fact that black
pussycat yeah yeah and as I was pulling
out Joe Mackey goes Sam hi how are you
and I go this is literally
geographically the exact same spot that
Joe Mackey is doing the exact same thing
yes in bumping mics I had my moment and
I was like this is this is exactly how
it happened but I didn't have anything
to invite him to so I just said hello
and made my way Joe is uh you know we
had a lot of great people on the bumping
mics and you know from like legends of
course Gilbert Godfrey oh yeah and it
was great to see the two of them
together have you seen that I have not
Bob Saget and Gilbert together no no out
of a match game or a other game show no
no it was great to see them together and
they and you know I gotta say one thing
about Gilbert like he definitely if
you're a comic like II love Gilbert like
you really do like and he really
completed the I guess you could say the
triad of me and Jeff like he he was
definitely like you know like a like a a
musket like it took him a long time to
load but when he shot everything in the
room and Bob is really cool so the the
young guys the you know we'll servants
and Joe Mackey and like there's so many
other like you know Nicky and Rachel
Feinstein and you know Amy and all
everybody showed up like from they just
came by and you know Michael che and
just like really cool people old
Michelle wolf so it was cool that they
all got on stage and like got to riff
around with us and you know Jeff and I
like we were just very impressed to see
everybody showing up and like you know
being such good sports so I was three
episode series to yes I was so impressed
I was telling Jim with the show yeah but
I said we need to not just book Dave
tomorrow we have the stars of bumping
Mike coming up here who only likes
coming up here the Twin Towers of rap
the fellow those guys were great I've
known him for a while but yet you knew
them well cuz he hang out outside series
everything every day yeah that's right I
think that's where Jeff met them
fighting this show how cool those guys
they're the greatest yeah I really are
at one point they wanted to inflict
bodily harm on me but not on that now
you're on this now aren't now we're on
good terms you have to what their
Christmas is like we'll find out what do
you I don't know same gifts for each one
of them just crappy yeah growing up like
that extra-long pair of jeans does one
on a beard and one doesn't now they
blame it the same very good that really
both look the same actually the one time
I brought them up here you know wait we
couple years ago
you know you need identification to get
into this building oh yeah I know right
so what a nerd right one of them had his
birth certificate folded up in his jeans
pocket and actually show unfolded it and
showed it to the guy down is good Wow
and they let him up and he came up here
and he in his birth certificate just
folded up in his pocket yeah why should
they should need just be able to like
look at him the half of the name is the
same like the last name yeah yeah I
could yeah I'm excited our birth
certificate here no I didn't either
lately it seems inconvenient anyway Wow
you know I got in with just a little
merch exchange I do I'm a big big Tim
Allen movie guy anything he doesn't
Santa makes me laugh you like this yeah
yeah yeah it's hilarious no but you know
it's the Claus yeah yeah sure no you
know it's good that they've actually run
out of Santa like stories and now
they're actually giving the reindeer
their do did you know that that
reindeers are now like starting to like
you know Rudolph the bed-wetter
I mean a lot are you getting to know
them outside of just like not attached
that's right right yeah and Rudolph so
much pressure to lead that thing it's
just pressing the bed every doll would
do it for the kind of money they're
offering now but I see I think there's
one where instead of like a reindeer
they have a zebra I forget what it is
but it definitely is like so many more
holiday movies than I remember us oh
yeah well the old ones though the old
classic what the Frosty the Snowman and
you know we're having these animations
yes didn't Burl Ives never lives yes
silver and gold
[Laughter]
I wonder how much money it took to get
him off the couch the moment you'll
watch the home alone series has become
part of the classic conversation of
social movie so is the one where the kid
gets his tongue stuck on the [ __ ]
thing a Christmas story yeah yeah and
what is that guy doing now he's an
optometrist or something I was like when
they don't you know that Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory kid oh yeah what he
becomes yeah he says he's a vet he's a
veterinarian that's right I saw it looks
kind of weird he's a great he's like I
had enough I'm doing about it you know
you know around one and out Rowling's on
the Christmas story is producing f is
for family on Netflix with Bill really
yeah he was in here wow that's cool yeah
yeah is a good gig was that a choice or
did he try doing acting he's like I'm
out you know they all try yeah everyone
still tries to come back but he said he
got to a point where he was like no just
do this behind the scenes enough enough
with all this it's the guy that can't
make the transition behind the scenes
they get [ __ ] right in the room hey
I'm right here Roeder yeah exactly what
about him I mean he was Ricky Schroder
at many transition in a Rick Schroder
and now we all still love him I was the
one cut off the Ricky I said keep it as
long as you can yeah Ricky maintained
what about let's see that another
holiday movie Grinch oh I love the
ground shaking about the animated talk
about the Jim Carrey I don't know I
don't know the new ones I'm like Jim I
kind of classic yeah Charlie Brown
Christmas yes I was always good yes
right we did the voiceover for that that
has to come out on afterbuzz that's
right Wow yeah well we just did it like
you know then sync it up yeah for fun
bunch of guys having fun right right has
been very kind to let me in the air and
tell me what you're doing over the
holidays but I was wondering what chip
Jefferson is good something better than
Jim Norton just loved it Dave phrased
that like he was a guest on a variety
show there's a lost-and-found somewhere
what are you doing Dave what do you do
for the holidays what do I do
yeah
like the subway sandwich in front of a
tire fire I don't really do anything I'm
just so glad to be not traveling I think
this is the worst time of year to travel
yeah and like you can already see it
like a week ahead of time like I was
coming out of LA and you're like this is
really cool like family it's like well
they'll pull their kids out of like a
week early at a school we're going to
the Bahamas right but I got a test
coming up don't worry about it you know
so I think that's really cool yeah pull
them out but it sucks for the travel so
anything look like I can stay local
that's why I'm like it's cool to be
Caroline's and Governors like just like
through this holiday season so that's
that's going on I think um you know we
all know it's gonna be freezing do you
think it's gonna snow on Christmas I
hope so like a white Christmas I put
down ten on good luck is it in my
favorite time of the year in New York
City is probably the week after New
Year's because everything just clears
out fine it just comes out that week
really I like the holiday this year's is
just depressing for some reason but I
tend to like the holidays I know I like
in the city it's just everything is so
difficult to get down in the city yeah
they're happening it's so crimes very
hard yeah
how about do we get to New Year's it's
empty I mean everybody flees the week
after New Year's you sure about that
well like right I mean the week like
right after New Year's Eve yeah that's
when everybody leaves yeah well I'll pay
what's full the gym that's right
everybody's their resolution that's
right then by February that [ __ ] fat
taking it up again nice great that's why
I always say I started I go I'm gonna
start going to the gym this year except
I'm not gonna go early cuz everybody
will know that this is just a corny
resolution I'll never go back and then I
just never end up going everywhere you
can't get a good [ __ ] in the locker
room anymore major issue why don't you
work out at home with a personal trainer
you earned it you think so
yeah why not I mean I guess I don't know
if I have the space at home you know to
create it yet Authentics that's probably
but you have a roommate because I would
suck if you had like a roommate you had
a personal trainer come over no I mean I
thought wife and a child oh well there
were mates I guess that would that would
be good wouldn't it be great to have
them over there how like your
your young child can see you working out
right and just sit there and going like
that this is a good role model see
physical fitness is just as important as
mental fitness and how exciting for your
wife to have a better looking guy coming
every day yeah don't need any guy test
her willpower yeah I don't need it I
don't invite men over to the house you
don't never why tempt them why why have
you ever been to Bethlehem PA I have yes
yes that would be a place for a
Christmas Allentown and Bethlehem I like
to do the tour you Sam yeah swing
through Harrisburg and then you do
Bethlehem occasionally a Lancaster gig
whoo things are going well so you don't
know yet what you're doing for the
holidays no I don't come over my house
train me why you come on over there come
over my house how old is your kid did
you have to like them put together a
bike or anything he is he'll be two in
February so he's just sort of starting
to put the pieces together is he into
dinosaurs he likes cars cars they're
very simple how about the transformer is
where they're both robots and now I'm
far too complicated he's very simple
nice and hard
it's Superboy again isn't that isn't
that the truth Jim is it electric cars
is that what he talks about doesn't even
need them Hot Wheels whatever they're
cheap easy just like me come on Sam cut
it out let's not be salty at the end